shiro à face à la caméra cachée de guéyo
tient aujourd'hui greg à louer une
voiture à un particulier
il va devoir la rendre ça va être un peu
problématique parce qu'il paraît qu'une
voiture et vous allez voir avec quoi il
revient c'est parti pour mettre en place
sa caméra cachée qui va suivre nous
avons passé une annonce indiquant que
nous souhaitions piéger une personne qui
pourrait me louer une belle voiture on
m'a alors mis en relation avec une
personne du nom de fred qui a accepté de
nous louer son véhicule cette voiture
c'est celle ci donc autant dire une très
belle voiture de sport dont la valeur
est estimée à 40 mille euros je retrouve
dans le fret sur le lieu de rendez-vous
on échange nos papiers on discute un peu
je lui remets l'argent correspondant à
une journée de location il me remet les
clés du véhicule
vous m'avez des caves et des rez euros
déjà pourquoi je n'y aura pas plus de
rigueur que c'est en tout cas la bonne
journée et à demain
le lendemain soir je retrouve fred pour
lui rendre son véhicule sur un autre
lieu de rendez vous nous avons placé des
caméras et la rive avant moi et
m'attends à rien juste un petit détail
que je n'ai pas précisé on ne va pas lui
ramener la voiture qu'il m'a prêté mais
celle-ci cette partie
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
vous allez bien ouais ça va voilà je
vais ramener une tour pour vous
remercier et merci merci moi je vous
laisse les clés voilà pourquoi je laisse
les cris etc l'idée
bah voilà pour les prêts je vais
poursuivre mes post une bonne soirée
alors pardon hein monsieur oui mais vu
comme un road show à la vôtre dire
celles que vous n'êtes pas ce qu'il y'a
laquelle audi tt rouge
en fait je vous ai pas dit j'ai un petit
soucis j'étais un restaurant que ma
copine mais après on allait faire j'ai
prolongé la soirée des amis fait on
s'est retrouvé à boire un peu j'étais un
peu éméché et du coup j'ai défoncé la
rambarde et du coup votre voiture allait
enfin elle est tombée
elle est tombée à l'eau dans la scène et
quoi avec des bulles et aux cétacés
nouveau blague ou quoi
est-ce que c'est quoi ça ça c'est la
voiture que je vous ramène à la place
assez novateur de substitution du coup
je vais enfin du coup j'ai pris les
devants et je suis passé chez mon nom
qui avait une équivalente à la vôtre
oeuvrait comme ça vous ça vous change
rien il ya un outil de vous plaît pas je
dois y aller soit vous prenez la voiture
mais si vous existez vous étiez vous et
vous vous allez vous vous rendez vous
est ce que pouvaient pas la tester le
produit avant avant de vous énerver
parce que si on dit la police moi je
vais avoir des gros problème j'étais en
état d'ébriété oui les gonzes ils
s'aventurent dans l'au delà si oui c'est
ça c'est qu'elle est dans l'eau
maintenant c'est pour ça tu veux pas là
aller à la police vous rendez vous
rigolez je vous ai donné un fort je vous
ai donné la voiture vous l'apprenait
vous la prenez pas regardez moi je vais
bien vous allez bien vous avez moi je
m'en fout de nous
avant de juger un produit testé leur a
donné sa chance au produit vous paraît
en tout cas c'est quoi cette histoire là
mais c'est pas ta merde regarder elle
trace sur la route et tout bon il ya
juste un petit bémol c'est que le
plancher prend l'eau ce que je vous
conseille cette conduit rambo presque un
petit souci dans mes deux mains car cela
empêche tout comment la femme que comme
moi vous convient à leurs bottes
moi je dois y aller en tout cas je vous
laisse la voiture vous avez les clés au
plus je vous ai fait une petite tour
pour vous remercier regardez vous le
prenez mal mais j'en ai rien à [ __ ]
château et les champignons bijoux en
voiture bon allez j'y vais c'est pas
grave vous des troupes ou les homos
combat alors c'est quoi cette histoire
là j'ai des amis qui habitent ici vous
voulez qu'on aille au chaud
voiture qui coûte 48 nouveaux et je me
suis dit que j'étais devancé
fred
écoutez moi ces fausses et quoi on me
dit la vérité hier parce que je voulais
vous rend nos meilleurs savez comment
faire quoi ces deux voitures
mettons nous dans la voiture mais c'est
froid ce matin la moitié de mon placard
et pourquoi vous avez certainement avoir
le permis du tas mais écoutez moi quand
même nom jean paul ricard à 2000 euros
faites moi votre permis monsieur venait
mais merde il est parti avec mes papiers
là je sais pas où il est vous sont faits
vas-y je lui dis oui fred c'était une
petite caméra cachée non je suis sérieux
venez je vous ferais je vous rend la
voiture c'était une petite blague je
suis juste un comédien en fait
venez vous êtes plus que ça je vous
attends même point de rendez vous
[Musique]
bonsoir
non non non non ouais mais non non non
tu devrais dire je pense à toi je
voudrais pas toute seule chose due
saab avait dit le tas